BEHIND THE
HURTING OUR WALLETS. PRICEE NEAN
UNDERSTAND
DAY,ERAGE
PRICE FOR  OISN.
GALLONS.'S5  GAS. OVEE COURSEOS
TH0 IF YOU FILL UP JMO
E  AGO.
COURSE OF A YEAR AVERAGECES HIT
AND YOU'LLPE00
GAST COASTE ENTY OF DRIVERELING
SEEING PRICES VELLON WATCH
AL- W
WORKOU AN EXTR1,CKMO
OIL PRICES SLIY
BU ARE
ENERGY GROUP
PR BUTS SO ABOUT
ER OF ITPEOPLE'S
MI W CAN>> PAMELA,OU
WHAT DSO PRICEPRICOF CRUDE OILWE
ION AN
LOCAL STATION.
TO ATT EDEPENDS ONANHEWHUTIN DES
OF SANCTIONINGHEUSSIANIL TWORLDD
'S THE BIGGEST OILPOS A  BGEU.S
SO UNF
OR.
ASE VE RUSSIA''VA PROBLEM
THAT'S BTHU. PRODUCERSE.
GALLON, ? WPECTOLE EGO?MEAN, E A
ING
IN UNE, PRESIDENT  SE  OF RESOLR
E, AND REI OFROMSI AWAY.PPS,OPT
$5 ON O THES HAVE TO JUP
INROD
KET.
OU HAVE THIS KINR GOESAWAY OR IF
THHAT REAYT THAT, B?>> YOU BET.
O RS NPORT OILD UNITED STATES
AN FUNGIBLE.RI.SO, EVY E THE UND
MARODUCEROCEBETREDLOBAL  PLD
SO'S PROCEMORE LIKE WE GETS OURL
OF WALVES OFF OR
INSULA OE
OCRYBODY  THI
IS HOW MUCH IA, DA
EVERYBODY  TS
PRECSEOIL
CANNOT BPLYWHE